de la précision du sang froid et de la
concentration des ingrédients
indispensables pour remporter le tournoi
national de black ball de
voisins-le-bretonneux la compétition
était organisée du vendredi 5 au
dimanche 7 mars au centre sportif des
pyramides les règles du black ball sont
aujourd'hui les plus pratiqués dans
l'hexagone
il y a six trous il y a cette vie jaune
sable rouge une bille noire nbi blanche
le but du jeu est de rentrer à l'aide de
la bille blanche
et si de rentrer les 7 bis de sa couleur
soit les jeunes soient les rouges et
l'habit noir an dernier en direct sans
mettre la blanche ça a été créé en
angleterre
justement pour avoir une petite table de
billard qu'on puisse installer dans des
salles à droite à gauche et donc s'est
joué dans le monde entier au total plus
de 400 participants dont les 32
meilleurs joueurs français se sont
affrontés sur l'e40 billard installé
dans la salle
c'est une étape 1 du championnat trans
d'auxonne qualification on vient ici
pour gagner le tournoi aussi pour
prendre des points pour se qualifier
pour pour le graal c'est à dire le titre
de champion de france
le numéro un français christophe lambert
a été éliminé en huitièmes de finale
dans la catégorie masters la compétition
a été remportée par christophe thé
borgias originaire de blois